that is the end of today's trip down  memory lane  but fret not in less than a week it's  the season two premiere of the drew  barrymore show and it is going to be  huge we've got mega celebrity guests  over the top segments i mean no one  would think i would do that the druziest  newsiest stories and  you've got a chance to win some serious  cash in a game we call six feet from six  thousand but that's not all  buckle up for something we're calling  bestie hour  and that means my bestie is coming back  yes it's an hour of me and cameron diaz  and we have a whole bunch of surprises  for a bunch of besties out there  you don't want to miss it cause then  what would you talk about with your  bestie i mean come on tune in september  13th and until then  [Music]